Bonsoir ce petit message vidéo pour
m'excuser de ne pas être des vôtres ce
soir car je suis malheureusement qu'on
finit à la maison j'aurais aimé débattre
avec le candidat Zemmour et j'aurais
aimé comprendre certaines logique de sa
politique par rapport à sa propre
histoire aussi qui est proche de la
mienne j'ai 10 ans de moins mais mon
père est arrivé en France dans les
années 60 en tant que réfugié politique
je suis né en France j'ai pris la
culture française je l'ai mélangé à la
culture hongroise de mon père j'ai
mélangé religion de mes parents
[Musique]
je suis devenu ce comme vous monsieur
Zemmour ce qu'est la France nous sommes
métissé et nous sommes mais qui sait de
souche maintenant il n'y a plus sur
fantasme de la France
au blanc la France catholique
n'existe plus depuis longtemps c'est une
notion obsolète vous savez pour faire
peur aux gens en parlant de grand
remplacement mais ce remplacement
n'existe pas il n'y a qu'une évolution
du monde le monde évolue les gens
voyagent le message est inévitable
comment allez-vous faire pour placer la
France dans un monde qui continue
d'évoluer en voulant la refermer sur
elle-même tandis que nous avons toujours
été l'étendard de cette ouverture ça tu
verras sur républicaine et démocratique
que nous défendons tous à travers le
monde et donc vous vous êtes un des
meilleurs exemple puisque vous êtes
capable aujourd'hui en étant fils de
juif algérien
de représenter de vous présenter
aujourd'hui pour être candidat à la
présidence française je trouve beaucoup
de cynisme à cette situation voilà
j'aurais aimé en débattre avec vous
merci
vraiment
parce que je
ne plaisante pas
avec lui
je l'ai trouvé
formidable
vous allez payer régler moi je
m'explique il a tout à fait raison pour
dire que lui
et moi
je n'aime pas le mot algérien parce que
je ne suis pas un Algérien
je suis d'Algérie en français
je sais mais bon
aujourd'hui mais vous avez tort
parce que là
il
mélange
ouverture République moi je suis un
français de confession juive
c'est-à-dire que je considère selon une
formule d'un autre je vais d'ailleurs à
professeur après le concert que mon
grand-père est Napoléon et ma grand-mère
et Jeanne d'Arc
dans mon sens il y a pas ça je n'étais
pas je n'étais pas à la bataille d'Eylau
et au côté de Murat je n'étais pas
encore moins envoyé avec Godefroy de
Bouillon allez d'accord mais c'est là le
génie de la France et c'est là qu'il ne
comprends pas le génie de la France ce
n'est pas ce qu'il dit le génie de la
France ce n'est pas le mélange comme ça
la diversité d'accord avec lui mais vous
avez tort le génie de la France c'est
l'assimilation et c'est le contraire du
racisme ça veut dire que nous
conviennent ou qu'on soit quelque soit
notre semble connais c'est la fameuse
formule de Romain Gary je n'ai pas une
goutte de sang français mais la France
coule dans mes veines c'est ça la
simulation c'est culturel et c'est
génial c'est nos ancêtres les Gaulois
alors que personne les Gaulois est-ce
que vous comprenez ce que ça ce n'est
pas et ce n'est pas ce qu'il décrit lui
donc je ne vais pas refermé la France je
vais simplement et quand il dit le mythe
de la France chrétienne et cetera ce
n'est pas un ami il n'y aurait pas de
France sans le christianisme il n'y
aurait pas de France sans la culture
gréco-romaine les immigrés qui sont
venues depuis un siècle est mis parce
qu'avant la France n'est pas un pays
d'immigration les pleins des pays
d'émigration depuis 1860 à peu près on
passe on se sont tous imprégné de cette
culture là et donc pour que la France
reste la France ça ne veut pas dire
instante asthme de pureté raciale mais
ça veut dire pour que la France reste la
France il faut que toutes les vagues
d'immigration s'imprègne et s'assimile
assez culture française qui est oui
imprégné de christianisme et de culture
gréco-romaine